and there you go
i was talking about how uh unsafe that
uh that remaining portion of the
building is
it has now collapsed we're not sure
whether that was another missile attack
that uh
uh that that brought the building down
completely but it has now
gone it was a missile i'm being told
[Applause]
at least two missiles hit the building
the remaining
part of the building that was left
standing after that first
missile strike some
25 minutes or so ago
all right i was telling you about um
missiles being fired
from gaza into israel they've reached as
far as
ashkelon ashdod tel aviv and other areas
in southern and central israel five
civilians
and a soldier have been killed there
let's bring in al jazeera's harry
fawcett who's live for us in
southern israel harry we're just looking
at
a another missile strike at least two
missiles uh hit the remaining part of
that uh that building
um that we saw uh
coming down here earlier this is the the
moment when the building was
uh was finally brought down harry that
was a building that that housed
media offices and and ground floor level
shops
yes i mean as far as the israelis are
concerned what they're saying
in bringing down these towers is that
they are
also being used in part uh whether it be
some apartments within them or or
something else
they're being used in part by fighting
factions within gaza and that makes them
legitimate targets especially given the
fact that they have been
ringing up building managers to clear
those buildings of
civilians before they take them down it
is also a huge statement of
power and a very visual statement of
destruction
in gaza and visible to
the residents of gaza and also hamas
passes palestinian islamic jihad and
others
what it also does of course is renders
hundreds and hundreds of people
homeless in the middle of a military
escalation so
there is a huge consequence to civilian
life
that is going to be felt by these big
destructive acts at the same time israel
is saying that it did
kill earlier on wednesday six senior
command
members of the hamas general staff
it says that they were among them the
head of the gaza city brigade and five
others who were involved in things such
as intelligence
and rocket production ten others who
worked in those areas also killed
in those uh attacks and that is
something
that has been confirmed by hamas is
almost certain to elicit
a major response from hamas in terms
of more rocket fire that's what the
expectation is in any
any event nonetheless the israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu said
it was making good on what he'd warned
of the day before
and he said that there will be more to
come
i said yesterday that these sons of
darkness the terrorists of hamas and
islamic jihad
they bear responsibility a short while
ago
we eliminated senior commanders in the
hamas general command
including the commander of gaza brigade
and other commanders
this is just the beginning we will
strike them with hits
they did not dream of
harry while all of this going on there's
a parallel crisis unfolding in
israel's mixed palestinian-israeli towns
and neighborhoods
yes that's right this is an issue which
is also very much occupying the israeli
government it's a crisis
of a related but different kind one
within the um one within the
uh the the country itself and the
communities themselves
the jewish and arab communities who live
here 20
of the israeli population is palestinian
israeli
and what we've seen is is after a
shooting dead of a palestinian israeli
man in lod
on monday night a massive funeral
which led to clashes with the israeli
security forces
and then an eruption really of violence
in many mixed jewish arab towns
particularly focused on lod where we saw
jews attacked with stones a synagogue
set on fire
also arabs being attacked as well in
various places
and so this is a real crisis for the
government they have
instituted a civil emergency in lod
they've put a curfew
in place uh due to come into force at 8
pm
tonight so less than an hour away and
three other cities as well
the border force usually used in the
occupied west bank
they have been deployed to try to
restore order the prime minister
benjamin netanyahu
uh pledging to use an iron fist to do so
uh and harry um let's talk about the
situation in israel itself
with with that barrage of rockets over a
thousand rockets now having been fired
from
gaza into uh southern israel a number of
uh
people have have been killed there um
what's the mood in the country itself
and
is there anyone at the moment who is
mediating between two the two sides to
perhaps bring an end to this
well to start with that point uh there
were efforts we understand from the
egyptians who have
acted as mediators in the past during uh
these
well it's difficult to say these sorts
of escalations because this is an
extremely
uh unusual rare and enormous one but
but yes there were efforts by the
egyptians to try to
to mediate but there seemed to be very
little
will uh to to step back from the brink
and those efforts in the short term at
least have failed
uh as for the uh the impact of what's
been coming out
from gaza as you say more than a
thousand rockets
an enormous amount of uh weaponry coming
out of gaza
targeting israeli cities most
notably there was that double barrage
in the middle of the night and earlier
in the evening on tel aviv
we've seen five israeli civilians killed
in those rocket strikes the most recent
were overnight
in lod as well a father and his young
daughter
both of them palestinian israeli
citizens and then
there was another attack early this
morning
when a uh an israeli military jeep came
under fire from
an anti-tank missile and one soldier
confirmed killed
two others were injured one of them
critically and so
as i've been saying that there is just a
feeling that
more and more of this is what we can
expect in the coming days
certainly a big response from hamas is
likely
in the coming hours and each step along
this road
the further both sides go the harder it
is to get back this is becoming an
extremely
it's already a deadly situation and a
dangerous one
uh it's almost looking irreversible that
there will be a
a still bigger conflict on the way al
jazeera's harry fawcett reporting live
from southern israel
harry many thanks indeed calls grew on
wednesday for a de-escalation from
nations around the world
china expressed deep concern and urged
all parties to exercise restraint
to avoid further casualties russia is
calling on israel to stop all
settlement activity in palestinian
territories
russia's president vladimir putin and
turkey's president recep tayyip erdogan
spoke on wednesday with erdogan
demanding that israel be given a strong
and deterrent lesson for its treatment
of palestinians
the eu says the priority should be
de-escalation
and the prevention of civilian deaths
germany says that israel has a right to
self-defense
against rockets being fired out of gaza
and the u.n security council has been
meeting for an emergency session on the
escalation
let's go live now to the white house our
white house correspondent
uh kimberly halcott is there for us
the u.s secretary of state has spoken to
his
israeli counterpart we're hearing
and the u.s secretary of defense has
spoken to
his counterpart the secretary of state
for his part asking for both sides to
cease violence complete what waters he
said
yeah this coming down just moments ago
the biden administration if we've
known for days has been working behind
the scenes
in private as well as public statements
to nudge
israel to de-escalate the tensions that
have been playing out across television
screens for days
apparently that nudging wasn't quite
enough and now we know the secretary of
state
just moments ago announcing that he is
sending an envoy to
the region in order to try and encourage
de-escalation according to anthony
blinken the deputy assistant
secretary of state for israel and
palestinian affairs
will be going to meet with israeli as
well as palestinian leaders the goal
again de-escalation the united states
saying it is deeply concerned with what
they are seeing
particularly in the last 24 hours in
jerusalem
gaza and elsewhere so this comes on the
heels
of a statement by the secretary of
defense
lloyd austin who has conveyed to his
counterpart
that the united states believes and
israel
has the united states ironclad support
when it comes to israel's what the
united states calls legitimate right to
defend itself and its people
they are condemning the launch of
rockets by hummus and they are
reiterating
the importance of restoring calm but the
question
that many have been asking here in the
united states even members of the
president's own democratic party
is do palestinians also have that right
to defense that the
uh united states government the body
administration continues to reiterate
that
israel has that right of self-defense
and this is still an open and unanswered
question so we're watching very
carefully
to see what more might come out of this
white house joe biden the u.s president
did not speak on this when he appeared
before reporters in the last hour but
there is a white house briefing coming
up the press secretary will be talking
we'll be watching carefully to see what
more she might add do you get the
impression kimberly that the white house
is perhaps
dithering here or has been caught off
guard that it doesn't really have
all its its ducks in a row as far as
policy is concerned
there's no question that that is the
commentary that is happening here in the
united states with respect to
the biden administration this
administration has made clear
what it wants to make its top priority
is dealing with covid19
is getting 70 percent of the population
vaccinated by early july
but the reality is is that even if joe
biden doesn't want to get involved
he is involved because historically the
united states
has given billions of dollars in
military aid
to israel add to that you have the
previous administration that was very
one-sided
with respect to its policy in the region
very much
favoring israel this is an
administration that says
it is going to listen to both sides that
it sees the only path forward
being a two-state solution they've also
spoken very candidly the white house
press secretary saying
that they believe when it comes to
israel that the evictions of
palestinians
have been working against the interests
of trying to resolve this long-standing
dispute and bring about peace
so this administration is looking for a
path forward
they're hoping that they can find
de-escalation diplomacy
but at the same time this is not the
priority that this administration
wants to be working on right now our
white house correspondent kimberly
halcott there live
in washington kimberly mini thanks
the palestinian authority is set to meet
in the coming hours to discuss the
escalating violence al jazeera's nida
ibrahim reports now from ramallah
in the occupied west bank one
element that the palestinian leadership
is focusing on
is the diplomatic effort is trying to
reach out to the international community
we've heard from
several palestinian officials who say
that the international community's
response hasn't been as strong as they
hoped for
we've also heard from the palestinian
prime minister
who says that this is a natural
explosion
because the reason for it is the israeli
crimes as far
as how much they put it the palestinian
president
mahmoud abbas has been holding calls
with different
leaders of the world including jordan's
king abdullah
as well as the iraqi president and the
you the eu's high representative
joseph borel
we'll take a quick break to get a
weather forecast here on alges here
we'll be back
with more coverage of developments out
of gaza and the biggest escalation of
violence there since the 2014 war